welcome back everyone to streaming the
galaxy my name is rocket riley and today
we're going to be going over a frame by
frame breakdown of pixar's new trailer
for light year the 3d animated film
featuring chris evans based upon the
real life character in the toy story
universe that the toy buzz lightyear is
based upon but before we get started if
you're new to the channel please hit the
subscribe button and click the bell icon
to be notified when we upload a new
video now let's take a deeper look into
all the clues and easter eggs you may
have missed in the trailer
the trailer starts us off with a status
check from mission control similar to
checks you may have seen in movies like
the martian or from real life rocket
launch sequences as buzz is zipping up
his jacket we also notice that he has o
positive blood while this likely won't
have an impact on the story it's just
nice to see that pixar never misses a
single detail
we also see a crystal-like structure in
a fuel cell inserted into the spaceship
due for launch likely as the main fuel
source for interstellar travel
we see the flight trajectory for the
ship as it launches around the sun using
its gravitational pull to perform a
slingshot maneuver deeper into space
next we see the mission control space
for the journey and the star command
logo is seen in the top left corner in
case you weren't aware star command is
the training and authority association
which manages the galaxy's space rangers
and cadets
this is a nod to the toy buzz's actions
in the first toy story movie as well as
the original disney series buzz received
titled buzz lightyear of star command
which ran for a total of four seasons
we also now know the release date for
the film which is june 17th 2022
the ship has a successful launch into
space and buzz then presses the hyper
launch button and puts on a frontal
shield propelling himself further into
the depths of space as buzz's ship flies
across the bright sun david bowie's
starman begins to play
we then see the base on which buzz will
likely be staying during his space
voyage and it looks quite similar to the
atmosphere of mars but we can see
condensation on the windows so it's more
likely a different planet we also see
buzz in his star command t-shirt another
nod to the original tv show
next we see a ship flying through
several rings in space maybe used as
launch points to a different destination
we see buzz hiding behind a rock along
with a robot who could be xr or
experimental ranger from the tv show who
was the first robot space ranger in star
command history we next see a scene that
looks eerily similar to the scene in
star wars the empire strikes back where
luke crash lands on dagobah the
forgotten swamp covered planet where
yoda trains luke to use the force
we then see what looks like a giant
launch portal on a planet with a
breathable atmosphere since buzz is
outside without a helmet we also see
several star command employees and an
officer who may end up being one of the
story's antagonist
we also see buzz's ship flying through
space sparking as he struggles to make
control of the obviously damaged ship we
see buzz playing with and being scared
by a toy cat while in one of the star
command bases
we see a robot giving a short lesson to
buzz and another ranger and based upon
the drawings on the whiteboard it seems
like the lesson is similar to the one we
learned from interstellar it looks like
due to the high light speed velocity at
which buzz will be traveling it will
seem like just minutes for him on his
journey while for others it will take
years
because of the hyper speed button buzz
pushes in the trailer every minute for
him will be like one year for those on
earth
buzz is then attacked by a green monster
likely similar to some of the monsters
we saw in the star command tv show we
then see the same toy cat attached to
the ship likely performing some sort of
function that assists with navigation
and we can see that the cat has a name
in the subtitles socks
we then catch a glimpse of the hornets
zerg's evil army of yellow robots seen
in the tv show as well
we also see a case opening up which may
contain the evil emperor zerg likely to
be the main antagonist of the movie near
the end of the trailer we finally get to
see buzz's traditional star suit with
the green and white accents along with
the classic wrist laser
the trailer ends with buzz and another
space ranger in their green and white
star suits who say to each other to
infinity and
leaving us all to scream beyond at home
this movie looks like it will provide
the story of a much more realistic space
ranger rather than the fantastical one
we saw in the tv series i'm so excited
to see what this movie brings especially
since chris evans will be voicing the
character of buzz it'll be great to see
movies like this which expand upon the
already established toy story universe
taking a completely new spin on the
action figure
well that's going to be everything from
us today on disney's newest trailer for
light year if you enjoyed the video
please hit the like button and don't
forget to subscribe for more great
content what are your theories about the
new trailer we'd like to know what you
think so drop your thoughts in the
comment section below from everyone here
at stream in the galaxy we hope you have
a great day and thanks for watching
[Music]
you